let me let me ju let's jump to this next
story so we can call out joe biden we
got this from the hill oh boy biden says
quote god willing i don't think we're
going to see a recession really y'all
god willing i don't think i don't think
we'll just put dot dots after that
joe so the bind administration that was
yelling said uh well they're all coming
out and saying this a recession is
normally two consecutive periods with
negative growth talking however that's
not really what a recession is so we're
not really in a recession even if that
is the case so thursday we're going to
find out if it's an official recession
which we all know it is and that's why
they preempted this by saying uh despite
the official definition of a recession
that's not a recession and moving
forward we won't see one
okay this is trying to reduce panic
this is just like at the beginning of
covid when they were telling us not to
buy masks yeah do we like it's all it's
all about lying because they don't
believe in the good will of
i tell people listening this
we can do what we can do we can speak up
we can try and uh
provide information to people we always
got to be calm reasonable and rational
and then when those people don't want to
listen there's only so much you can do
you can you can bring a horse to harvard
but you can't make them learn you
however you can go to a store and buy
beans that will last you for a few years
you can stock up on emergency water
emergency food you can get out of cities
now some people tell me
yo i can't afford to leave the city
totally get it totally understand it's
not easy i'm sorry i don't have answers
for everybody i will tell you that there
may come a time where things get so bad
in cities and i say may come a time i
don't know where you're like it is
preferable to just start walking to
leave everything behind strap on my
shoes and walk out of that city if say
like the water system fails or something
like that i'm not saying it will i'm
saying for the time being if you can't
afford to leave the city it basically
means that the way you live in the city
is a better standard for you than just
being homeless and wandering through the
woods that i understand
times may come though so do what you can
as my point yeah guys make sure you have
passports i know a lot of americans
don't have passports so if you don't
have a passport please get one but do
you know why they don't
because they never leave but you know
why they don't leave it's a big country
it's a big country
the united states is about as big as
europe is and it's quite xenophobic
people are told at least i was growing
up that the outside world's very
dangerous the outside you know outside
the united states you'll get you might
get attacked on the street and you know
there's some truth to it you go to south
america the cops are bribed you know
you've got to be careful where you walk
is more dangerous than a lot of
countries new york cities it's a jungle
so it's a mechanical jungle it's always
funny because like you guys know i grew
up in the middle east i grew up in saudi
arabia and it's very funny how people
have this idea of that being some super
dangerous place i'm like bro it's safer
than literally everywhere in the usa let
me let me say the problem with these big
cities
um
let's say
you have a chicken and that chicken
takes a dump right in the middle of your
yard
you don't you don't think twice you
don't care yeah the rain comes a day
later that poop is long gone
what happens if two uh 20 tons of
chicken crap plopped right in the middle
of your yard it's a lot of bacteria yeah
i'm sorry rain's not going to wash that
away it's going to be months and it's
still going to be there it'll be
festering it's going to be that's a city
yeah so it may so
i've argued with like michael miles for
instance about overpopulation and
climate change i think it's a problem
and then ultimately come to the
agreement well population density in
cities is a problem sure agreed these
cities are bad what do we do to get
people to stop
being in cities i mean for one the
cities are struggling to maintain
themselves but also
when all of these humans when you get
like 10 million humans in one area all
taking a dump at the same time that goes
into one place the rain and the water
can't wash it away you spread those
people out over a few hundred square
miles and now the rain can deal with
that and the earth can you know
rebalance everything what i don't get is
i'm looking at the world economic forum
website we well weforum.org i think
that's it but the world the world's mega
cities they want to build mega cities by
2030s of course they do i don't
understand this logic because if they're
if they're centralized dangerous
starvation
uh vulnerabilities why would they try
and make more of it you just explained
it
like they want to control people's views
they're not good people bro
you're you're thinking under the see
this is the problem that
normal decent kind and compassionate
people have is they
it's it's really hard to understand
someone like willfully doing something
that is
cruel or harmful to others you can't get
your head around it because you're
always trying to think well they must
mean well
and there are people who don't
there are people who don't right there
are people who do not care about human
beings and do not care about humanity
and they're not good people so you can't
view them through this lens of them
wanting to
help you
i'll give you give you a good example
adam kinzinger okay i think he's the
perfect example of
he doesn't care about people who's who's
that i'm not sure he's a republican on
the january 6 committee okay and he's
going off and off about trump and how
the republicans are bad and all that
stuff but this guy's not running for
reelection all he's doing is setting
fire to the house as he leaves
he could say look clearly this is not
for me clearly what's happening in this
country is problem i'm gonna i'm i'm out
i'm leaving right now instead he says
i'm not gonna run for the election but i
am going to inflame tensions to the most
extreme degree possible starting fires
before i go yeah there's no reason to do
that it's a real thing i mean dude you
see this on a small scale on social
media every day
right there are people on there
fortunately you know they don't have
like giant followings or a lot of
influence and power but they're purely
they're they're purely destructive right
it's purely destructive and malicious
energy there's nothing
positive that they're doing they're
literally just they're trying to hurt
people trying to bully people trying to
attack people and they're doing it day
in day out right now you take someone
with that type of psychology and you
actually put them in a position of power
and influence
like what are they going to do again
we've seen this in history
and there are people like that who exist
it's a very very tiny minute fragment of
the population but there are eight
billion people in this world perhaps so
there are millions and millions of uh
trolls perhaps an emerging phenomenon
you think troll will ever have some
taboo to say
right perhaps it's an emergent
phenomenon
that when meritocratic individuals
create a safe and secure society it
protects individuals who normally would
not survive those people
who can't survive who use words like
adulting because they can't live on
their own without someone like better
adulting
like well you might have to fight a bear
for food one day or something these
people can't survive you end up with a
large portion of anti-meritocratic
individuals who don't make systems work
they vote against the interests of those
who do and the system flips over the
boat collapses the strong of course
climb up learn to swim and survive and
all of those weak people get
gulagged or whatever it's the adaptable
it's the ones that get capsized and
figure out how to get to shore to
rebuild society again that are the ones
that survive it and the strongest may
just go down because they don't think
quick enough they're so used to their
own
system that they've created and they're
very good at it that when the system
capsizes they don't understand right but
that's basically what it means it
doesn't mean a guy who can lift 50
pounds it literally means those who are
capable intelligent and understand are
likely to perceive threats plan ahead
effectively and survive it's a darwin
quote it's not the strongest of the
species that will survive but the ones
that are most adaptable to change right
so basically
that's the general concept
when
when a crisis is happening who's most
adaptable to change well first and
foremost the people paying attention who
are watching it come and that aren't
connected to any one ideology let's say
there's a bunch of people in a tribe on
an island and half of them have been
noticing something weird happening on
the shoreline
they're paying attention and the other
people are like we don't care we don't
care nothing's going to happen well the
people who who are who noticed the
change are the ones who are more
adaptable and then they go we're going
to go climb that hill real quick and
then the tsunami comes and everyone else
gets wiped away yeah people that are
like god will save me like get that out
of your mind right now you save yourself
perhaps
i mean i disagree with that framing of
it no one at least i hope no one thinks
that like
i don't know if they're on the street
and they get mugged that jesus is gonna
come save them from getting mugged i
don't think they think that they're
talking about their spiritual
you can't just like it's not their
physical
i know it's it's comforting to think
that there's a being that's protecting
you but it's not you got to protect
yourself in this harsh reality i mean
they're talking about spiritual
protection right not
like famine won't happen because jesus
will save us from famine like that's not
it's not gonna not happen i can't i
don't know no one thinks no one thinks
like that i hope i hope so it's the
suffering is like the cornerstone of
like the christian faith so buddhism too
some people some people certainly
believe it there are people who believe
that god is a man in the clouds like
sitting there watching everybody that's
just one ideology don't think the
government's gonna save you don't think
god's gonna save you don't think your
neighbor's gonna save you like you have
to protect yourself and your interests
what's the saying god helps those who
help themselves yeah that's true there's
another saying uh chance favors the
prepared you can call it any way you
want it if you are not doing what you
have to do to be prepared for what might
be happening well then like what's going
to happen like i think look having ha i
think to you know
options are always good
and i think that
something that people should really know
by now is to
just just have options right have
options in terms of places you can live
ways you can earn money
things you can do don't be so
i don't know like maybe because of how
i've grown up and the fact that i travel
so much
i've got
i know i have a different view than most
people but i think that we were talking
about the big cities and i think that
something that really happens of course
is just inertia
right like it's hard to if you're used
to a place especially if you've grown up
somewhere and you live there and your
friends and families are there and it's
what you know
it's hard to
up and move i understand that it can be
difficult emotionally it can be fine
financially you might have a job or a
career like there it's i'm not saying
that it's just super duper easy for
everybody but i think that seeing where
just the level of uncertainty in so much
of this stuff
it is wise to
just bear that in mind and take take
steps don't just sit there and say oh
you know the the end is coming
it's like okay take take some steps if
you haven't already been doing it over
the past few years take some steps so
that if stuff does hit the fan or you
are getting very uncomfortable or
whatever it is you've you've got options
having options is always wise thanks for
checking out this clip from timcast irl
come hang out live monday through friday
at 8 pm eastern time super chat we'll
even answer some of your questions if
you want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time